folks once again thank you for clicking
on my mug and before we get started i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by raycon i
did pinky up for a second
we're getting classy here raycon earbuds
are those slick stylish true wireless
earbuds that do remain as i always say
my workout earbuds the reason is very
simple you're slick discreet no dangling
wires or stems
if you have to fall out of my head no
matter how you slice it
that ain't bad as always raycon earbuds
offer six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth powering more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit they also come in a
variety of fun colors don't be limited
get your fine aesthetic on
and they have a 45 day free return
policy i always appreciate the fact that
you can buy with confidence so click the
link in the description or go to
buyreicon.com
john's to get yourself 15 off your recon
purchase and thank you once again to
raycon for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now guy
richie and jason statham return that
should have been the title of this movie
[Music]
wrath of man the wrath of man's directed
by guy richie jason statham stars in it
so yeah that's the return of guy ritchie
directing
the jason statham starring jason
statham's characters new to the job of
armored truck driver and then people try
to rob
armored trucks because they're loaded
with money and jason statham
stathams them okay
you know how it's gonna go down it's a
movie called wrath of man starring jason
statham it doesn't take much to deduce
the fact that the guy is probably not
reading the great gatsby in front of a
fireplace or anything you know people
are gonna die
and they do but there are certain
expectations with a movie that's
directed by guy richie that stars jason
statham you know you might be looking
for that snatch flavor
i'm out i'm out you know what i mean i'm
talking about the vibe in terms of its
execution that's where you can see like
oh yeah guy richie's fingerprints in
here because instead of being linear it
does things where it's like oh you see a
little bit of something and then in that
pulp fiction-esque kind of way it goes
back and you see a little bit of the
backstory and you see
the same situation but another angle and
you see you know it's that execution
that makes it feel fresh
not in that rotten tomatoes kind of way
you know
fresh versus rotten you know charge is
it makes it feel a bit unique
it being jason statham starring it is
the jason statham show yeah absolutely
does the guy know he's being
filmed i don't know but i do love the
fact that he can kill somebody in his
jason statham manor kind of way and be
like eat your own dick
it's a megalodon statham's good at what
he does and funny i think back to the
movie snatch
he was turkish in that movie he wasn't
the badass he is now but that's where
you can't go into this movie with those
expectations of it feeling like an early
guy richie movie even though jason
statham's in it it's kind of like you
know when a musical artist or group that
come out with that album
you know it's been 10 or 20 years like
hey here's the new album and people
might expect it to feel exactly like the
old album like their debut album and it
doesn't but in its own right it's still
good music that's what this is like but
it's also where it runs into a bit of
identity crisis also because you have
these guy rich equips happening
especially in the setup of this movie
now it's like why does this
sound why does it feel weird it feels
weird because the tone the overall tone
of the entire movie
isn't really that is so it felt a little
conflicting for me the movie's dark man
this is some dark even the musical
score sounds like the musical scored a
joker
which is great like i i love the musical
score to joker
i have that soundtrack vinyl yeah flex
that's a little bit but i like it i
think it sounds great what can i say and
it works
for watching a person just circle the
drain to madness kick ass
jason statham movie where he has to
dispatch some folks
who are trying to rob armored cars with
that guy richie tone he's just you know
it feels a little conflicting for me
he's just a more mature
almost jaded much darker guy richie then
again you look at snatch
there was a mobster who would cut people
up and feed him to pigs
but still the tone was lighter the quips
were that of fun you know we were here
for a good time it had that energy yeah
i'll take some light-hearted things like
bricktop i was wondering at a point why
this movie felt long
like the movie feels like it's not long
it's two hours long
which i mean it's not that's an average
movie two hours and i think it's because
the way the movie's
told where you have to go back and you
already you had your setup then at a
point you go back and you see
some other setup so you're like i'm
watching the first act of the movie
twice but two different first acts and i
think that does something
in terms of the audience processing the
movie at least for me it just made the
movie feel longer because i was watching
a first act twice it almost feels like a
gta movie
actually that's a really good way to
describe wrath of man it's a gta movie
comprised of a few gta missions that
make one movie that said i had a good
time with it i'm keeping it vague
because
the execution and the the slow trickle
of reveals
that's the fun of the movie absolutely
the stakes are higher
at the very least personal and it's a
movie of no heroes just
you may have a protagonist but that's
that's very loosely i thought jason
statham once again was great in this
character that he is
very known for playing but there's a
complexity to this jason statham
s character there's a damage here that i
really liked i thought the gentleman was
more
in line to what people think like at
least myself what i think when i think
guy richie movie but i thought in the
end wrath of man i thought it was a
really cool movie
solid time no alcohol required alright
so wrath of man have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite
recent guy richie movie whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you